Progressing in one's chosen career is not simply about showing up for work every day, so what do you do to succeed? In this episode, we speak with one psychologist who is helping young scientists create individual development plans, or IDPs. He, along with colleagues at the American Psychological Association, has put together a set of short YouTube videos that spell out how IDPs can get your career on the right track from the start. IDPs are a tool that rely upon self-assessment. Identifying your career goals,
在所选职业中取得进步不仅仅是每天按时上班，那么你该如何获得成功呢？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，他正在帮助年轻科学家制定个人发展计划（IDP）。他与美国心理学会的同事们一起制作了一系列简短的 YouTube 视频，阐述了 IDP 如何从一开始就让你的职业生涯走上正轨。IDP 是一种依赖于自我评估的工具。明确你的职业目标，
your values and your skills and abilities. When done correctly, they provide a framework for developing career milestones that move you towards a desired career outcome. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. Garth Fowler is the Associate Executive Director for the Office of Graduate and Postgraduate Education and Training at the American Psychological Association. He has developed and delivered hundreds of seminars and workshops for young scientists who are just embarking on their careers.
你的价值观、技能和能力。如果执行得当，它们将为你制定职业里程碑提供一个框架，推动你实现理想的职业成果。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。加思·福勒是美国心理学会研究生与博士后教育培训办公室的副执行主任。他为刚开始职业生涯的年轻科学家开发并举办了数百场研讨会和讲习班。
Specifically, is an expert on creating and implementing individual development plans. These are programs that help students and postdoctoral scholars achieve their career goals. Welcome, Dr. Fowler. Thanks for having me. What exactly is an individual development plan and how does it help a student successfully launch a career? An individual development plan is a resource that individuals can use to actually plan out what their career trajectory is going to be. It's a series of steps that they go through that involve looking at their own skills and abilities, what their own interests are, doing research on the type of careers out there that utilize those skills and those abilities and that might match their interests, and then trying to put down and say, well, if I really wanted to have that job, say, in two years or three years, what would it take for me to really be competent and successful? to have someone look at my resume and say, that's the person I want to hire for this job because
具体来说，他是创建和实施个人发展计划的专家。这些项目旨在帮助学生和博士后学者实现他们的职业目标。欢迎你，福勒博士。谢谢你的邀请。到底什么是个人发展计划？它如何帮助学生成功开启职业生涯？个人发展计划是一种资源，个人可以用它来规划自己的职业轨迹。它包含一系列步骤，涉及审视自己的技能和能力、明确自己的兴趣，研究那些能利用这些技能和能力并可能符合自己兴趣的职业类型，然后尝试写下来并思考：如果我真的想在两三年内得到那份工作，我需要具备什么条件才能真正胜任并取得成功？让别人看我的简历时会说，这就是我想要招聘的人，因为
they are matching what I need right now. We know, specifically these individual development plans, we're talking about all kinds of careers, but specifically we're with the American Psychological Association. So let's focus a little bit on psychology careers. You know, we know there are a lot of options out there for graduates with a psychology degree. They may not be always terribly obvious, you know, leading to this impression in some quarters, that there aren't a lot of jobs for psychology graduates. Is this true? You know, what should psychology graduates are people interested in psychology as a career be focusing on in order to be
他们符合我现在的需求。我们知道，特别是这些个人发展计划，我们谈论的是各种职业，但我们特别是在美国心理学会。所以让我们稍微关注一下心理学职业。你知道，我们知道心理学专业的毕业生有很多选择。它们可能并不总是非常明显，你知道，这导致某些方面产生了一种印象，即心理学毕业生没有多少工作机会。这是真的吗？你知道，心理学毕业生或对心理学职业感兴趣的人应该关注什么，以便
successful? Yeah, I think you're right. There is a lot of right now bad publicity for psychology majors and for lots of majors that if it doesn't really track to a specific job, then it's probably not worthwhile doing. And I think one of the things that an IDP helps people realize is that jobs out there and careers are not actually just titles. There are compositions of skills and competencies and abilities that make you successful or that you need. And so I would say anyone who is majoring saying psychology develops a lot of skills and abilities that they can use later on. They get quantitative skills. They get analytical skills. They become experts in understanding how behavior works and how, say, the brain works. And those skills, those abilities to think broadly
获得成功？是的，我认为你是对的。目前对心理学专业以及许多专业确实存在很多负面宣传，认为如果它不能直接对应到某项具体工作，那么它可能就不值得去做。我认为 IDP 帮助人们意识到的一点是，外面的工作和职业实际上不仅仅是头衔。它们是由让你成功或你所需要的技能、能力和素质组成的。所以我认为任何主修心理学的人都培养了许多以后可以使用的技能和能力。他们获得了定量技能、分析技能。他们成为了理解行为如何运作以及例如大脑如何运作的专家。而这些技能，这些广阔思考的能力
and be analytical are very useful in a number of careers. Of course, as you move further through what we call the educational pipeline. So as you go from being an undergraduate to say a graduate students with a master's degree or an individual with a doctoral degree, you are focusing more on a specific set of careers. So if you're getting a doctoral degree, you're probably really interested in say either doing professional services or doing research or doing both. And so I think the idea here is to tell people, think, you know, think clearly about what kind of skills and abilities you acquire during your education and training. And also think clearly. clearly about the jobs out there and what they're asking people to do. Like in my particular job,
和分析能力在许多职业中都非常有用。当然，随着你在我们所谓的教育管道中不断前进。当你从本科生变成硕士研究生或博士学位获得者时，你会更加专注于一套特定的职业。所以如果你正在攻读博士学位，你可能真的对从事专业服务、研究或两者兼顾感兴趣。所以我认为这里的想法是告诉人们，清楚地思考你在教育和培训期间获得了什么样的技能和能力。也要清楚地思考外面的工作以及它们要求人们做什么。比如在我的工作中，
I don't do research near, but I'm still very analytical. I have to look at data. I have to look at reports. I have to look at information that's coming across my desk about the status of, you know, the employment and training and be critical and analytical about it. And that was training I got in my doctoral program in a very different way. So I would say we hear that, oh, there's no jobs for a psychologist or there's no jobs for these types of people. But I would say the skill set you have, is applicable to a lot of very rewarding jobs. You just have to think about it in that kind of competency and skill set. Well, what can be done to better inform psychologists about their options?
我并不做研究，但我仍然非常善于分析。我必须查看数据、报告。我必须查看办公桌上关于就业和培训状况的信息，并对其进行批判性和分析性的思考。这是我在博士课程中以一种非常不同的方式获得的训练。所以我认为我们听到有人说，哦，心理学家没有工作，或者这类人没有工作。但我会说，你拥有的技能组合适用于许多非常有价值的工作。你只需要以那种能力和技能组合的方式去思考它。那么，可以做些什么来更好地让心理学家了解他们的选择呢？
I know you're working on some YouTube videos to help students put together individual development plans, as we talked about. Can you talk about that? And is this anything new? Well, I'll start with the second part. IDPs really aren't new in that regard. You ask what the biggest challenge is, is helping graduate students and postdocs learn about all. the different jobs out there. And that's the biggest challenge. How would someone learn what I do
我知道你正在制作一些 YouTube 视频来帮助学生制定个人发展计划，正如我们所讨论的那样。你能谈谈这个吗？这是什么新鲜事吗？好吧，我从第二部分开始。在这方面，IDP 确实不是什么新鲜事。你问最大的挑战是什么，那就是帮助研究生和博士后了解所有外面的不同工作。这是最大的挑战。别人怎么会知道我是做什么的
unless they actually say shadow me or call and talk to me or something like that? And so part of the IDP resource that we're developing is giving examples and providing ideas and describing approaches to learning more about all the different jobs out there. And one of the things that we talk about in the IDP is something called an informational interview where you essentially would find someone who, say, someone would be interested in my job. They meet me at a conference. They could send me a follow-up email later saying. I was really impressed by your talk about IDPs,
除非他们真的跟随我观察，或者打电话跟我交谈之类的？所以我们正在开发的 IDP 资源的一部分就是提供例子、提供想法并描述了解所有不同工作的途径。我们在 IDP 中谈论的一件事叫做信息访谈，你基本上会找到某个人，比如有人对我的工作感兴趣。他们在会议上见到我。他们以后可以给我发一封后续邮件说：我对你关于 IDP 的演讲印象非常深刻，
and I am also interested in graduate development, education, and training. Would you mind if we had coffee after, you know, tomorrow's session, and you can just tell me in 20 minutes a little bit about what you do, how you got there, how your training matched what you. And actually, when most people get an email, like that, they're happy to respond. Right. It sounds really intimidating, and it's hard, I think, sometimes to get graduate students and
我也对研究生发展、教育和培训感兴趣。你介意我们明天会议结束后喝杯咖啡吗？你可以用 20 分钟简单告诉我你是做什么的，你是怎么走到这一步的，你的培训是如何与你现在的……实际上，当大多数人收到这样的邮件时，他们很乐意回复。没错。这听起来真的很吓人，而且我认为有时很难让研究生和
postdocs to do that. But that's one of the ways to go out there and say, well, how would I get a job like yours, or are there other jobs like yours? Like, do other associations have individuals in charge of graduate and postgraduate education and training like we do at the APA? And would I be able to, you know, apply for that job or would I be successful? So I think that's the biggest challenge is getting them to think beyond, oh, well, most people who usually studied psychology ended up being X.
博士后去做这件事。但这是走出去并说：好吧，我该如何获得像你这样的工作，或者还有其他像你这样的工作吗？比如，其他协会是否有像我们在 APA 那样负责研究生和博士后教育培训的人员？我是否能够申请那份工作或者我会成功吗？所以我认为最大的挑战是让他们跳出“哦，通常学习心理学的人最终都成了 X”这种思维定式。
When the data shows right now in workforce and reports that come from the National Science Foundation and from National Institutes of Health and other groups, that's not the case in where. There used to be this really what we call traditional track for, and it's not there. That's fewer opportunities in some regards. There's not as many faculty positions that there used to be. But there's also a lot new, a lot more new opportunities. that people should be investigating. And so that's, I think, the biggest challenge
当数据现在显示，来自国家科学基金会、国立卫生研究院和其他团体的劳动力报告中，情况并非如此。过去我们所说的传统轨道，现在已经不存在了。在某些方面机会减少了。教职岗位不像过去那么多了。但也有很多新的机会，人们应该去调查。所以我认为这是最大的挑战，
and that's where we're trying to really focus. And frankly, maybe more creative and interesting careers than you have ever thought of. I mean, we have highlighted in science and action and on our website, you know, people who work playing video games all day. They have a PhD in psychology. I mean, it's not saying that, you know, people out there that that's what you should be doing you're focusing on.
这也是我们真正试图关注的地方。坦率地说，也许比你想象的更有创意、更有趣的职业。我的意思是，我们在《科学在行动》和我们的网站上重点介绍了那些整天玩电子游戏的人。他们拥有心理学博士学位。我的意思是，这并不是说这就是你应该做的事情，你专注于此。
But, you know, thinking outside the box seems to be a really big focus right now, not only in psychology, but other careers as well. I think you're right. It is kind of this thinking outside the box. And it's also taking an advantage of just seeing what people are willing, you know, what people are doing. So I like your example of playing video games where I went to graduate school, Microsoft was right across the river. And you would be surprised at how many people with graduate degrees were getting hired by Microsoft to do things like, let's product test this, you know, part of Microsoft Word. Let's have this, let's have that. And psychologists are well versed in. to have that type of job. They might have to learn some computer coding on the side, but then that's a new skill set that you've added, and here you are doing something really amazing and different with your degree. So let's imagine I'm a psychologist, I'm not, but let's imagine I am. I have a fresh new doctorate. I'm heading to my first postdoc position or maybe my
但是，你知道，跳出框框思考似乎现在是一个非常大的重点，不仅在心理学领域，在其他职业中也是如此。我想你是对的。这确实是一种跳出框框的思考。而且这也是利用机会去看看人们愿意做什么，人们正在做什么。所以我喜欢你玩电子游戏的例子，我去读研究生时，微软就在河对岸。你会惊讶于有多少拥有研究生学位的人被微软聘用去做诸如“让我们测试一下 Microsoft Word 的这个部分”之类的事情。让我们有这个，让我们有那个。而心理学家非常精通于从事那种工作。他们可能需要在旁边学习一些计算机编程，但那是你增加的一项新技能，在这里你用你的学位做着一些非常了不起和不同的事情。所以让我们想象我是一名心理学家，我不是，但让我们想象我是。我刚拿到博士学位。我正前往我的第一个博士后职位，或者也许是我的
first job. You know, what are the first things I should do when I start this new job to make sure I'm getting the best out of that experience and to position me for the future? Yeah, so that's a good question. And in our video series, and the resource that we're developing, we actually start with some characters. We kind of storyboard this and say, you know, this is Hunter. We pick two characters.
第一份工作。你知道，当我开始这份新工作时，我应该做的第一件事是什么，以确保我能从那次经历中获得最大收益，并为未来做好准备？是的，这是一个好问题。在我们的视频系列和我们正在开发的资源中，我们实际上从一些角色开始。我们把这个故事板化，说：这是亨特。我们选择了两个角色。
Their names are Hunter and Amanda. And we're both about to start their postdoc. And we actually walk through, you know, two ways that you could approach it. And one is just arrive and hope someone tells you what you're going to do today and they have a plan over the next two years or however long this is.
他们的名字是亨特和阿曼达。他们都即将开始他们的博士后研究。我们实际上走过了你可以采取的两种方式。一种是直接到达，希望有人告诉你今天要做什么，并且他们对未来两年或无论这段时间有多长有一个计划。
That's going to get you somewhere. And if you just come in and hunker down and work really hard, When the two years is over, you'll find a job. Or the other approach is to come in and think critically about what you're being asked to do, what your job and daily requirements are, but also how do they help you develop new skills, new abilities? Where's the opportunity to say, maybe I'm not so great at public speaking? So while I'm in this postdoc, I'd like to try and get more opportunities to do that
那会让你有所成就。如果你只是进来埋头苦干，两年结束后，你会找到一份工作。或者另一种方法是进来，批判性地思考你被要求做什么，你的工作和日常要求是什么，以及它们如何帮助你发展新技能、新能力？有没有机会说，也许我不擅长公开演讲？所以当我在做博士后时，我想尝试获得更多机会来做这件事，
because someday I would like to be a spokesperson for psychology careers at the APA or something like that. So we tell people, when you start a new phase of your training or a new phase, of your career, sit down and think, what am I going to gain from this? What opportunities are there for me? And think, well, what would be the next set of jobs I could take that would match that? So it's kind of thinking a little bit forward. It's kind of maybe trying to predict. That's where it's hard. Like, can I predict exactly what jobs are going to be open? I don't think you can, but you can develop a really broad skill set so that when a new and interesting job comes across your desk, you'd be like, I'm really qualified. I should probably apply for that job just to see what would happen.
因为有一天我想成为 APA 心理学职业的发言人或类似的角色。所以我们告诉人们，当你开始培训的新阶段或职业的新阶段时，坐下来思考：我将从中获得什么？有什么机会适合我？然后思考：我接下来可以从事哪些工作来匹配这些？所以这有点像向前看。这有点像试图预测。这就是困难所在。比如，我能准确预测会有什么工作空缺吗？我不认为你能，但你可以发展一套非常广泛的技能，这样当一份新的、有趣的工作出现在你面前时，你会觉得：我非常有资格。我应该申请那份工作，看看会发生什么。
So what if you're not a psychologist or a psychology major? What other fields are these IDPs useful for? And when should people start developing one? Yeah, that's a really great question. And we're starting to see this idea of an IDP going across all disciplines and all stages of education, which I think is really exciting. But it also really, I think, drives home the idea that during your graduate education or during your post-doctoral education, One of the things you should be focusing on is developing competencies and skill sets that will serve you for the rest of your life, not just writing one paper that will get you the next job or something like that. Great. Well, Garth, thank you so much for joining us. Appreciate it. Thanks for having me.
那么，如果你不是心理学家或心理学专业学生呢？这些 IDP 对哪些其他领域有用？人们应该什么时候开始制定一个？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我们开始看到 IDP 的概念跨越了所有学科和所有教育阶段，我认为这非常令人兴奋。但我也认为它真正强调了一个观点，即在你的研究生教育或博士后教育期间，你应该关注的一件事是发展将为你余生服务的竞争力和技能组合，而不仅仅是写一篇能让你获得下一份工作的论文之类的东西。太棒了。好吧，加思，非常感谢你加入我们。很感激。谢谢你的邀请。
To see the IDP videos and to learn more about the IDP process, please go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要观看 IDP 视频并了解更多关于 IDP 流程的信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。